you posted the paper you co-authored was
rejected from europe's as you said
proudly in quotes rejected
can you joke yeah i know
can you describe this paper
and like what was the idea in it and
also maybe this is a good opportunity
to ask what are the pros and cons what
works and what doesn't about the review
process
yeah let me talk about the paper first
i'll talk about the review we'll talk
about the review process
afterwards um
the paper is called v craig so this is i
mentioned that before variance in
variance covariance regularization and
it's a technique a non-contrastive
learning technique for
what i call joint embedding architecture
so siamese nets are an example of joint
environmental architecture so john
travelling architecture is
let me back up a little bit right so if
you want to do cell supervised running
you can you can do it by prediction um
so let's say you want to train the
system to predict video right you show
it a video clip and
and you train the system to predict the
next the continuation of that video clip
now because you need to handle
uncertainty because there are many you
know many continuations that are
plausible
you need to have you need to handle this
in some way you need to have a way for
the system to be able to produce
multiple predictions
and the way the only way i know to do
this
is through what's called a latent
variable so you have some sort of
hidden vector of a variable that you can
vary over a set or draw from a
distribution and as you vary this vector
over a set the output the prediction
varies over a set of plausible
predictions
okay so that's called i call this a
generative
latent variable model
okay
okay now there is an alternative to this
to handle uncertainty
and instead of directly predicting the
the next frames of the of the of the
clip
you also run those
through another neural net
uh so you now have two neural nets one
that looks at the
the uh you know the
initial segment of the video clip
another one that looks at the the
continuation during training right
and what what you're trying to do is
learn a representation
of those two video clips that is
maximally informative about the video
clips themselves
but
it's such that you can predict the
representation of the second video clip
from the representation of the first one
easily okay
and you can sort of formalize this in
terms of maximizing return information
some stuff like that but it doesn't
matter
uh what you want is
uh informative representative represent
you know
informative representations of the two
video clips that are mutually
predictable
what that means is that there's a lot of
details in the second video clips that
are irrelevant
you know
i let's say a video clip consists in you
know a camera panning the scene there's
going to be a piece of that room that is
going to be revealed and i can somewhat
predict what the what that room is going
to look like but i may not be able to
predict the details of the
texture of the ground and where the
tides are ending and stuff like that
right so those are irrelevant details
that perhaps my representation will
eliminate
and so
what i need is to train this second
neural net in such a way that
uh whenever the the
the continuation video clip varies over
all the plausible continuations
the representation doesn't change
got it okay so it's the yeah yeah got it
over the space of representations
doing the same kind of thing as you're
doing with similarity learning right
yeah so so these are two ways to handle
multi-modality in a prediction right in
the first way you parameterize the
prediction with a lithium variable but
you predict pixels essentially right in
the second one you don't predict pixels
you predict an abstract representation
of pixels and you guarantee that this
has track representation
has as much information as possible
about the input but sort of you know
drops all the stuff that you really
can't predict essentially
uh i used to be a big fan of the first
approach and in fact in this paper with
this mishra this this blog post
the dark matter intelligence i was kind
of advocating for this and in the last
year and a half i've completely changed
my mind i'm now a big fan of the second
one
and it's because of a
a small collection of algorithms that
have been proposed over the last uh
year and a half or so two years
to do this
including v craig
its predecessor called barbie twins
which i mentioned
uh
a method from offensive deep mind called
byol
um
and and and there's a bunch of others
now that kind of work similarly so
they're all based on this idea of joint
embedding some of them have an explicit
criterion there is an approximation of
mutual information some others are byol
work but we don't really know why and
there's been like lots of theoretical
papers but why be where it works no it's
not that because we take it out and it
still works and
i mean so there's like a big big debate
but um
but the important point is that we now
have a collection of non-contrastive
joint embedding methods which i think is
the best thing since sliced bread so i'm
super excited about this because i think
it's the best shot
for techniques that would allow us to
kind of build uh
predictive work models and at the same
time learn hierarchical representations
of the world where what matters about
the world is preserved and what is
irrelevant is eliminated
whether the representations the before
and after is a cr in the space
in a sequence of images or is it for
single images uh it would be either for
a single image for a sequence it doesn't
have to be images this could be applied
to text it could be applied to just
about any signal i'm looking at you know
i'm looking for
methods that are generally applicable
that are not specific to you know one
particular modality you know it could be
audio or whatever got it so what's the
story behind this paper this this paper
is what is describing one of the one
such method this is this vikrant method
so the cisco authored the first author
is a
student called adrian bard who is a
resident phd student at fair paris
who is co-advised by me and jean ponce
who's a professor at economic superior
also a research director at indriya
so this is a wonderful program in france
where phd students can basically do
their phd in industry and that's kind of
what what's happening here
and this paper is a follow-up on
uh
the this barlow twin paper by yeah my
former post-doc now stephan dunny uh
with
li jing and and joris montar and a bunch
of other people from from from fair
and one of the main criticism from
reviewers is that v craig is not
different enough from bother twins but
you know my impression is that
it's you know
bottle twins with a few bugs fixed
essentially and uh in the end this is
what people will use
right so but you know i'm used to stuff
yeah that assume it being rejected
forward so it might be rejected and
actually exceptionally well excited
because people use it well it's already
decided like a bunch of times so i mean
the the question is then to the deeper
question about peer review and
conferences i mean computer science as a
field is kind of unique that the
conference is highly prized
that's one right and it's interesting
because the peer review process there is
similar as opposed to journals but it's
accelerated significantly well not
significantly but it goes fast
and it's nice way to get stuff out
quickly uh to be reviewed quickly go to
present it quickly to the community so
not quickly but quicker yeah but
nevertheless it has many of the same
flaws of uh peer review because it's a
limited number of people look at it
there's bias and the following like that
if you want to do new ideas you're going
to get pushback
um there's self-interested people that
kind of
can infer who submitted it
and kind of
you know be cranky about it all that
kind of stuff yeah i mean there's a lot
of you know social phenomena there um
there's one social phenomenon which is
that because the field has been growing
exponentially
the vast majority of people in the field
are extremely junior yeah so as a
consequence and that's just a
consequence of the field growing right
so as the number of the size of the
field kind of starts saturating you you
will have less of that problem
of reviewers being very uh
inexperienced
a consequence of this is that you know
young reviewers
i mean
there's a phenomenon which is that
reviewers try to make their life easy
and to make their life easy when
reviewing a paper
is very simple you just have to find a
flaw in the paper right so
basically they see their task as finding
flaws
in papers and most papers have flaws
even the good ones yeah
um so it's it's easy to you know
to do that you your job is
easier as a reviewer
if you just focus on this but what's
important is
like is there a new idea in that paper
that is likely to influence
it doesn't matter if the experiments are
not that great if the protocol is you
know
uh so so you know things like that as
long as there is
a worthy idea in it
that will influence the way people think
about the problem
um even if they make it better you know
eventually i think that's uh that's
really what what makes a paper useful
and so
this combination of
social phenomena creates a a
disease that
has plagued you know other fields in the
past like speech recognition where
basically you know people chase numbers
on uh
on benchmarks
and and it's much easier to get a paper
accepted if it brings an incremental
improvement on a
sort of mainstream well-accepted
method
or problem
and those are to me boring papers i mean
they're not useless right because uh
industries you know strives on on those
kind of progress
but they're not the ones that i'm
interested in in terms of like new
concepts and new ideas so uh papers that
are really uh
trying to strike kind of new advances
generally don't make it
now thankfully we have archive archive
exactly and then there's uh open review
type of situations where you and then i
mean twitter is a kind of open review i
i'm a huge believer that reviews should
be done by thousands of people not two
people i agree uh and so archive
like do you see a future where a lot of
really strong papers it's already the
present but a growing future where it'll
just be archived
and
you're presenting an ongoing continuous
conference called twitter and slash the
internet
uh slash archive sanity andre just
released a new version uh so just not
you know not being so elitist about this
particular uh gating it's not a question
being elitist or not it's a question of
uh being basically uh
recommendation and city of approvals for
people who don't see themselves as
having the ability to do so by
themselves right so it saves time right
if you rely on other people's opinion
and you trust those people
or those groups to evaluate a paper
uh for you
um
that saves you time because you know you
don't have to like scrutinize uh the
paper as much you know it is brought to
your attention i mean there's a whole
idea of sort of you know collective
recommender system right
so i actually thought about this a lot
um
you know about 10 15 years ago uh
because there were discussions at
um nibs and you know and were about to
create iclear with yoshi banjo and so i
wrote a document kind of describing a
reviewing system which basically was you
know you post your paper on some
repository let's say archive or now
could be open review
and then you can form
a reviewing entity which is equivalent
to a reviewing board you know
of a journal or a
program committee of a conference
you have to list the members
and then
that
group reviewing entity can choose to
review a particular paper
spontaneously or not there is no
exclusive relationship anymore between a
paper and a venue or reviewing entity
any reviewing entity can review any
paper
or may choose not to
and then you know give an evaluation
it's not published not published it's
just an evaluation and a comment which
would be public
signed by the reviewing entity
and
if it's time by reviewing entity you
know it's one of the members of
reviewing entities so if the reviewing
entity is you know
lex treatments uh you know preferred
papers right you know it's lex friedman
writing a review yes what so for me one
that's a beautiful
system i think but what's in addition to
that it feels like there should be a
reputation system for the reviewers
for the reviewing entities not the
reviewers individually reviewing
entities sure but even within that there
are viewers too because uh
i it's there's another thing here it's
not just the reputation
it's an incentive for an individual
person to do great
right now in in the academic setting the
incentive is kind of uh
internal just wanting to do a good job
but honestly that's not a strong enough
incentive to do a really good job in
reading a paper and finding the
beautiful amidst the mistakes and the
flaws and all that kind of stuff right
like if you're the person that first
discovered a powerful paper
and you get to be proud of that
discovery
then that gives a huge incentive to you
that's that's a big part of my proposal
actually who i described that as
you know if if your evaluation of papers
is
predictive of future success yes okay
then your reputation should go up as a
reviewing entity
um
so yeah exactly i mean that um i even
had a master's student who was a
master's student in uh library science
and computer science actually kind of
work out exactly how that should work
with formulas and everything but so in
terms of implementation do you think
that's something that's doable i mean
i've been sort of you know talking about
this uh to sort of various people like
uh you know andrew mccallum who
started open review and the reason why
we picked open review for iclear
initially even though it was very early
for them um is because my hope was that
uh iclear were it was eventually going
to kind of
inaugurate this type of system so iclear
kept the idea of open reviews
so where the reviews are you know
published with the paper which i think
is very useful
but
in many ways that's kind of reverted to
kind of more of a conventional type
conferences for everything else and that
i mean i
i don't run i clear i'm just the
president of the
foundation but um
you know people who run it should make
decisions about how to run it and i'm
not going to tell them um because they
are volunteers and i'm really thankful
that they do that so
but i'm saddened by the fact that we're
not being
innovative enough
yeah me too i hope that changes uh yeah
because the communication science
broadly but communication computer
science ideas
is
how you make those ideas have impact i
think yeah and i think you know a lot of
this is um because people have in their
mind
kind of an objective
which is you know fairness for authors
and
the ability to count points basically
and and give credits accurately
but that comes at the expense of the
progress for science
so to some extent we're slowing down the
progress of science
and are we actually achieving fairness
and we're not achieving fairness you
know we have biases you know we're doing
you know double blind review but
uh
you know the the biases are still there
there are different different kinds of
biases
you